[Music]
season three right around the corner
how would you describe it I personally
like season three more than the season
two why storyline is really interesting
it's completely completely different
mystery and season two which is very
dark but I like it
my vibe Vanessa Morgan filling Riverdale
season three secrets and Choni fans get
excited
[Music]
what can you tell me about choking we're
going hot and heavy
we had a kissing scene last episode that
was great what other side was that
so five yeah we're getting steamy
[Music]
what is share alike it's a serpent she's
a vet honestly she's a badass as a
serpent she's been like taking over
yeah actually just kind of been like I'm
comfortable here just kind of made it
like HBIC except for with the serpents
you know yeah she's been Archie Andrews
you're under arrest for the murder of
shadow Lake resident Cassidy Bullock
what I didn't kill him have the right to
remain silent
season three picks up right after
Archie's arrest and get this it only
brings everyone in Sweetwater closer we
will survive whatever you have planned
because we are ending we pick up right
there and then we also pick up by the
farm which is the you for the farm it's
like we're buddies momma's and colleague
how does our cheese arrest affect things
this season it does it get resolved
right away is it something that takes to
us all right away but I think it
definitely brings us all the kids
together and try to come up with a
solution only six episodes into filming
but things are looking good for Archie
and Veronica and Jughead and Betty Kevin
also finds love everything to be good
hot and heavy right now and kevin has a
boyfriend this is so exciting as a
boyfriend so yeah it's all good right
now but we're only in episode 6 do we
approve of Kevin's boyfriend does he fit
in with everyone
what do you love most about that
relationship what do you think fans are
gonna love most I feel like because
Kevin human has needed a love like a
love in his life for so long so it's
kind of like spin that build-up and
moose never like left his girlfriend so
now that was you know available it's
kind of cute seeing them together like
that people will love it okay describe
it in three words the premiere episode
freaky 10 and juicy
[Music]
Oh somebody help
[Music]
[Applause]